welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question it's the show that
gives you too much information about
what would happen if our favorite people
got a terrible deadly infection oh that
that's our leader yeah that's that's out
of context oh I'm Erik Bosse here with
football you know how you doing man hey
we the black polo boys look yeah look at
their cycles have Hawaiian oh we've been
aligned for since college this is true
what they say about their sync up
underneath all my shirts I have the same
three shirts that you have hey so let's
talk about what infection were really
like we're talking about symbiotes or
symbiosis you're wrong and don't know
anything yeah oh she's fantastic
well Philip one of the few break let's
see she was with Chris Evans by the way
wait what
Jenny Slade backup Jenny slate who's
very funny actually was with Chris Evans
who is very everything else all right
I'm gonna whack off from Ken what do you
mean with like with with with with like
width with WI dt8 with ya Wow yeah well
this is so good about that I was like
god he's he adopts shelter dogs that is
not I'm not making a joke about Jenny
slate I just rented he I just read that
he adopted his talking about alter
[Music]
I just read that and there was a picture
and it's very cute and then he also
dated Jenny slate undulate is a catch
both of them are gay this has become a
different show this is like a gossip
column this is hot boss with hot Goss
all over again can we get that tight
lamination no no yeah symbiotes yeah
let's talk it because one of the few
bright spots at the end of this long
tunnel it's gonna be venom to let there
be carnage kind of a weird name movie
that we're pretty excited about we've
been wondering what's the deal with the
symbiotes what's the deal with these
symbiotes as Jerry Seinfeld is being
covered in a big question for you this
week what would happen if the Venom
symbiote or any symbiote attached to
Marvel heroes or villains who aren't
Eddie Brock other Marvel characters what
happened if they get splashed with the
symbiotic it happens a lot and it always
it's always super interesting because it
changes that character in specific ways
like we've talked about how it taken
over spider-man is the reason it should
be the reason for the logo it's almost
trying to mimic the logo on the costume
when it's a logo for no reason it get
kind of is a little weird but whatever
you need to make toys I get it
it's the reason for all this as we
learned from Rick and Morty this week
merchandise Morty your only purpose in
life is to buy and consume merchandise I
want to go through just there's so many
instances of various symbiotes being all
over various characters that I just
picked a couple of specific ones that I
think are interesting I just realized
that that dream I had about one that was
a symbiote dream by the way go back
watch our previous episode if you're not
sure who Lynette is this has really been
underneath it all the whole time it's
like when a dog tries to talk oh yeah
Kyle is doing great by the way
what's gonna be episode though okay so
the first symbiote that I want to
discuss this just shows you right out of
the gate how like distant the two things
can be of what the symbiote is and the
kind of characters that we can get on so
I just want to show you right here I'm
gonna show you a picture of Rocket
Raccoon covered in specifically in Venom
symbiote he looks insane why am i
looking ahead this is okay he's like
like a hedgehog now kind of and he looks
spiky as hell okay
he's just so scary and he's all black
and white but my favorite detail about
this is rocket is known for his blasters
his guns become symbiote guns of course
they do I love this they're absorbed in
the with the rest of the organic stuff
sure uh trigger warning a little too
late if you have Tripta phobia his guns
kind of give me a little bit of the
tingles in the bad way oh I don't know
what the bad way means but it's bad
you have tripped a phobia doing i
defined Tripta phobia define Tripta
phobia that gross thing when a lot of
holes appear very close together to each
other and it makes you feel uh not good
Tripta phobia
it's a weird trigger that is an
invention of the modern age and a weird
phobia that's in a vision in the modern
age you know our grandfathers didn't
have to worry about this no I think they
did because it's evolutionary because it
looks like certain poisonous things you
shouldn't eat you'd have to believe in
evolution crazy
we were monkeys then why do monkeys
still exist for someone who is a biology
major and asked that question that was
fun I remember a very good friend of
ours still thinks dinosaurs are
currently around and we just watching
this right now so that's that's great i
Drax pulls the symbiote off of rocket
and then Drax gets covered in venom goo
as a reward number two interesting miss
Carol Danvers herself
Captain Marvel she's actually helping
spider-man spider-man you know Leo
spider-man the nice boy
door then it possesses her and it goes
on a rampage the cool thing about when
she is covered in but I'm now venom can
fly oh and venom is very excited about
being able to fly as Miss Marvel so cool
thing that like if you can make venom
any more powerful it's like because he
currently does the like really intense
kind of you can tell by the way if you
know what I'm a bender to time to talk
we're doing we're doing the Spider Man
dance stupid thing about it God dangit
if they didn't like really enforce that
logo rule it is like the gold stripe
fully across the chest the whole star
thing
yeah the logo rule is so dumb but it's
like a dumb rule that we want well cuz
we want to know who look different on it
otherwise it all look like black goo but
still it's like in on the symbiote
planet it's gone so commercial there
that individuals every individual has a
logo oh wait that is just what a name is
[Music]
it's what a name is and it's also like
what's your brand like bro what's your
brand mine is confusing to people black
polos oh it's confusing cos it's art we
both have the same brand we're exactly
the same that's what you don't follow me
on Instagram Mamma Mia that's a spicy
meatball now thinking about epic ASSA T
of the symbiote attachment what of the
symbiote the epic ASSA t the thickness
of the epicness okay I I love that song
what is that is there a song called
viscosity what is wrong with you heart
you know that actors like I kicked in
the head and now she only hears music
we're talking about Ted Danson's wife
Mary Steenburgen yes in the head and now
everything is music to her yeah I've got
an experiment
safety glasses it's like that episode of
scrubs yeah except in real life - and
she got kicked in the head and she
married it today I think Ted Danson did
it he's a nice guy but not always that's
the best of both worlds I mean wake up
the Ted Danson and hear music yeah
Danson is my music so the epic hasta tea
most significantly epic character that I
got oh I'm already sweating you're
thinking about Ted Danson area and some
venom goo man that episode of rogue
theory by the way I was so sweaty for
the end yeah are you okay I am very okay
my eyes were bulging at the end of that
yeah you were like Total Recall Phillip
at the end of that the next one Erik
Silver Surfer Silver Surfer was
subjected to not venom but carnage
attachment oh no this is terrifying the
craziest detail about it is that because
Silver Surfer well not really but in
certain movies derives his power from
his board the goo gets over the board
- and the board also becomes a carnage
board what if the carnage board look
like red
okay fair yeah it kind of looks like a
venom had just kind of a lion's mane I
was back and just a surfboard a red
surfboard it's a really cool surfboard
surfboard sir Bjork the only thing it
actually didn't change that much though
for for Silver Surfer or carnage carnage
now though had the ability through his
tendrils to send a little little cosmic
Sam I guess that's probably a step up
from like going down your throat ripping
out your organs like yeah yeah just a
little cosmic sap blast instead that's
what that feeling is when suddenly your
butthole hurts really bad and really
what happened it's like God give you a
little cosmic guy got the symbiote on
him you can tell by the way I do that I
make you butthole hurts Silver Surfer by
the way had just destroyed a planet of
symbiotes when he did this by somebody
Galactus so then like there's some
complicated stuff he convinced his
spider-man that'll to get this
give it back to Cletus Kasady to save
his life some reason but it was there's
a good reason but still it gets
complicated not worth going into don't
even read it okay yeah the pictures
better carnage comics storylines you can
read here's a great one that's not who
you think it is but Wolverine okay
is it will attach to venom but it's
actually 2300 baby snake would you call
her baby's nicht we said that that you
dead word should be read not said here's
the thing about x-23 so change wise very
similar except venom now instead of
anywhere venom was white venom is now
yellow and blue and it kind of like
looks kind of cool here's where like I
just gotta be honest with you all right
no one's listening to this right yeah
this is just going up to our private
channel right I don't ever look at the
views or the yeah yeah we subscribe to
each other's only fans and we're the
only fan it's by definition you can only
have one person oh yeah I'm not only fan
comm not only fans so admitting
something here she's so hot it's like
weird it like like her head it has a
little bit of the xenomorph going on
which you know I'm early into we're all
into xenomorph that's fine and then she
got you know the the dual like rock on
cuz
she has weirdly like the tightest venom
body you've ever seen and like really
defined sculpted venom boobies okay how
old is he it was at this moment that he
knew he dumb we should have led with how
old is he be overly legal she entered
the universe in x-men evolutions and she
was a kid she was like a like a 13 year
old and then in the movie she was like
10 okay in 2017
it looks like she was around 19 to 20 so
barely legal and then somebody else was
like well an all-new Wolverine she
really is coming off 16 to 18 and that's
this little area spacious is from all
new Wolverine let us know if I'm going
to jail
send me to prison this look all I said
is that
she has a tight pod and that's not
illegal god I'm digging the hole
there's no okay way to describe this
it's like when you watch female
gymnastics and you're just like I can't
say anything you know this house except
when you watch them you're impressed by
their athletic skill and have no other
opinions much just just Wow moving on
nope I hope they didn't know Larry
Nasser that's all you hope Oh God Eric
no you don't judge you look at you you
don't get to reveries Larry Nasser we're
we're in this pit together
moving on very quickly to somebody who
is definitely of age but equally sexy
would type in I've got attached to
Galactus oh yes please
here's ice queen so here's an
interesting thing that that answers how
much can the suit stretch all right how
much can you symbiote keep extending
itself I guess it keeps replicating its
cells because it's able to cover all of
Galactus everything it actually like
isn't real
it's a giant robot that Mysterio made to
scare spider-man okay but let's just
assume like that's like what we're what
we're looking at i what I think it's so
ho stupid about it is that it is just
like venom with a hat on because it's
trying to reference Galactus but it just
doesn't make sense it still has that
little stupid like fancy loincloth thing
genitals but venom doesn't have that so
there's just nothing back unless I guess
khalaqtu psy was like collective's
Galactus has his major dong behind that
and like they did have to cover it
remember that really funny movie major
dong you want this Wiener to serve in
the military can you imagine this is how
they bring Galactus into the MCU what or
I guessed into the the sponge bump key
are we officially calling it that yeah
SP um see it's pump see this balloons
nice spoon states might might take the
Sony Pictures universe of Marvel
characters Siri just got activated
because of that whatever that'd be
really good it goes way to bring him in
yeah
moving on this one sounds really
interesting
cute courage has been attached to the
symbiote turns out very boring you know
why they got the same powers oh yes sir
stretch and not good English literally
like they had the same powers and the
biggest change is that he says I am
venom instead of I am group oh okay just
feels like a joke yeah are we a joke to
you but if it were baby group what a
dancer you can tell them okay here's my
append rules I'm baby Groot he's a baby
he is by definition underage he's a baby
he's baby baby potted plant man it's all
hitting a lot harder this week there's
like a couple of versions actually
Deadpool has warned venom multiple times
and then specifically between spider-man
and Eddie Brock Deadpool got in there
once and they had adventures together
some of the more interesting stuff I
guess because he has Venom's powers he
can kind of do webbing which is cool but
then also he's like he's very confusing
colors now so you can see in the picture
here so everyone thinks he's spider-man
he's gonna prefer to as a spider already
kind of a thing that happens honestly I
think it's like a really good look like
yeah I think Deadpool should just kind
of constantly adopt a venom just see you
Dobson
well that's precious Deadpool isn't just
like you know able to heal whatever he's
also extremely skilled martial artist
and we saw with rocket that the weapons
were coming to play so also the
tentacles can like wield guns and swords
simultaneously and he can shape-shift
into a bunch of different shapes and he
has the you know Fang mouth and claws
but here's something really fun they're
together they're called venom pool when
venom pool happened it was it's set in
the past so people say the reason that
venom is crazy and evil is because he
broke his mind when he was with Deadpool
cuz Deadpool is so freakin insane I
think that is honestly like a great way
for there to be a little bit of a
crossover with like Deadpool and
spider-man and venom or something just
like seeing actual like movie Deadpool
covered in the SEBI I think would be
very funny yeah I mean Deadpool is going
to be like this secret weapon for the MC
once he crosses over because that guy is
like the conduit for anything any model
any point of confusion and just bring
him in there
he'll smooth it over he'll get venom in
there he'll make a joke and we'll all be
cool with it and it'll canonize
everything just turn everything into
cannons this is kind of the one that
launched this whole question for me
because this is the one I was the most
curious about exactly I'll play it out
and it's fairly recent actually that you
can see this and it's a time that venom
attaches to the one and only incredible
oh okay in this scenario Eddie Brock is
wearing venom and venom actually decides
to abandon Eddie for the much stronger
hero of the Hulk which makes a lot of
sense honestly and this is something we
talked about in our recent broke their
episode where it was like you know venom
might decide that Eddie's not worthy of
a holding
[Music]
then Bruce Banner gets killed during the
transformation process by carnage but it
somehow leaves the Hulk behind still so
he still becomes venom Hulk which is the
most powerful version of venom as of yet
and basically just a completely on
killable version of venom these little
like weird things about it so very cool
it just can create like new limbs but
like Hulk style limbs very weird and it
actually negates the Mysterio Galactus
idea is that there isn't actually enough
venom to go around to actually cover the
Hulk so instead the symbiote has to keep
moving and like kind of touching all the
different Hulk spots until he giggles or
just I guess just to constantly keep
them as covered as possible also Red
Hulk head the symbiote at one point and
also at the same time was inhabited by
Ghost Rider like the spirit of vengeance
at the exact same time which is a very
cool idea moving on though and we're
almost wrapped up here danos Thanos has
been wrapped up all in carnage which is
the most like terrifying of the company
yeah except is not in the comics it's
again I always feel grateful of being an
adult man who watches TV shows for
children in the spider-man TV cartoon
show crossover with the guardians of the
galaxy
danos bonds with carnage but here's just
the coolest thing about it danos is so
like solid mentally that he actually
controls carnage carnage is not like
able to be insane
I just a knows now has extra powers as
like Danos carnage like he needs extra
power yeah I guess it didn't really
increase his powers that much because he
doesn't really need them but he was able
to still try to create the symbiote army
and it's carnage Stannis yeah
two left here that I just thought were
interesting this one is just some people
in case people don't know DC totally has
their own version of venom where they
kind of like ripped it off it's called
black box and black box is basically a
symbiote and it becomes a character
named Black Rock another stuff but black
rock covers infects plastic man but to
save the day
is Batman Batman gets infected by
Blackrock and also Superman gets
infected by Blackrock and this is more
complicated as more people can have it
but what's really close just for Batman
it gave him a bunch of superhuman
abilities so he had super strength super
endurance he could project energy he
could fly and he could absorb energy so
of course he just like uses it to kick
Superman's ass cause it's like oh I mean
if Batman has Superman's powers and then
finally there's probably the most
complex symbiote attachment that has
ever happened you might have remembered
it when you read on my old man Logan
because it's a very quick thing that is
just true in that in that world and
that's when the symbiote when venom
attaches to attacks it's just a big old
t-rex they actually sit so it's not
explained in old man Logan but they
actually since I've gone back and
explained it through Hawkeye that
Hawkeye and Cape Bishop led a bunch of
symbiotes to the savage lands to be
eaten by T Rexes but then obviously one
of them has taken over at t-rex you know
in terms of how it changed their powers
I got a wonder what a t-rex is powers
are just being able to read intent today
yeah I mean the best yeah third graders
obsession just it's a more intense
obsession for that third grader and it
just called venom Rex or venom source
Rex of course that's what happens when
you get covered in goo kids you gain
more power no kids
damn it this show is not meant for
children unless we're meant for
everybody this is on YouTube right yeah
this is a only fams isn't about time
only Christian version of oh yeah that's
very interesting very informative
Phillip especially since I you know just
basically stay away from infections
because you never know where that rabbit
hole will lead before we get on to some
bite-sized questions I'm gonna answer we
just want to give everyone watching a
look under the hood a little bit you may
have seen in some other videos we're a
small business we're struggling to get
through this period YouTube is not
making it easy for us the hair basically
you know give it
pennies on the dollar in terms of AD
santino or views are okay the government
isn't picking up the phone we're
basically on our own lately so one of
our ways to try to get through this is
by partnering with other small
businesses who are in the same boat and
one small business has been really great
about trying to get some desperately
needed hand sanitizer in all of our
hands is a company called sanitize and
chill
boom legitimately this is a company that
we are directly partnering with normally
I know you guys are used to us talking
about other brands those are you know
Big Boy brands that are descending from
the mountaintop to hang out with us and
be nice to us this is just a company
where we actually just know the people
and work together to try to help both of
our companies out so here's the deal
with sanitizing show they combine
hospital-grade ethanol based hand
sanitizer with CBD CBD has a lot of
positive benefits reduces inflammation
No and as Phillip said we know these
people we've been checking up on it
ourselves we don't want to get behind
anything that isn't actually gonna help
you kill viruses on your hands with that
other medical professionals look at this
we've been able to meet the highest
levels of guidelines but the thing about
CBD there's no THC in it you're not
gonna get high by using this on your
hands they'll just help your hands get
clean and the reason why it's a color
green it's got aloe vera in there so
it's gonna help your hands stay smooth
there's other benefits to travel there
is you know ya Teeling aloe vera is like
to Hispanics is like Tylenol take it
with everything yeah or two Greeks
Windex yeah each bottle contains 100
milligrams of CBD the alcohol content on
the sanitizers above the 60% that the
CDC recommends for inactivating the
viruses are all worried about it's at
70% alcohol content it's stronger than
those brands that you know you see on
the shelves we took for granted that are
no longer there right now or like crazy
marked up on retail so here's the deal
folks there's a limited supply of 2,500
bottles because of you know it's a small
company that we're working with it's
less now already actually so if you're
looking for hand sanitizer if you want
to help us I here at new rock stars act
now go to bitly calm /nr chill and use
the code new rockstars 10 at checkout
for 10 percent off your order it's a
good deal real quick again super just
reiterating here this is us Eric and
Philip partnered with a dist analyzer
company the people we know because we're
both just trying to help each other's
company
so this actually does make a huge
difference if you buy this and I'll
really quick say actually the CBD
content
I put CBD on my hands already every
single day because I have bad joints and
I work out a lot and it might hands get
tight real easily and they don't want to
put CBD cream in and now I just use that
because it has hand sanitizer and CBD in
it I love it yeah this stuff's great
yeah alright let's move into some bite
size questions that I'm gonna handle hit
me with ya all right are you ready
though I don't know Eric okay throw a
bite-size question at you if you're not
ready I used to think I was ready for
everything in life and now I'm just like
taking things as they go and if I'm not
ready I don't I don't shame myself yeah
and you know Charlie's just waiting for
the moment you're not ready and he's
just gonna oh we're talking about
Charlie Schneider right okay he is all
he's ready everything he's he's work or
he's he's already ready for these
questions he's already answered then oh
yeah uploaded immediately I think that
guy is like hero from Heroes you can
just like wait he's not the one who sees
the future heroes the Asian guy anyway
what were you talking about Golden Girls
whatever happened to them oh no they
thanked us for being their friends
they're in a risk category Ruby wants to
know should there be a crater or a crack
in the surface whenever somebody pulls
off a superhero landing I like this
a great question this does happen
sometimes like in the matrix you know
Morpheus lands it creates it cracks the
pavement or cracks the cement and then
that was based on ghost in the shell'
when major would do that and she's like
part machine Iron Man's landing
sometimes and then see have cracked to
the ground ant-man is cracked the ground
they were crack to the tile but here's
the thing about it it's actually more
likely that a crack shouldn't form in
the pavement it's super unrealistic when
that happens if it's like a human body
because Newton's third law would mean
that any forces strong enough to crack
pavement would also be applied to your
bones in your body and would break your
bones
so when Deadpool does that Deadpool
loves to call it out in the movies he
does it a tipple - it actually hurts his
knees he complains he gets up angel dust
does it in the first one she doesn't get
injured because she's like a super
durability body IRA make a crack
pavement because he's got an armored
suit with shocks in it we think because
otherwise if he doesn't have shocks in
that suit is his body should just be
like flesh soup could you imagine like
the very first time he lands like
peppers like how was your flight and it
opens it just liquid pours out when you
see characters do it it's either
characters who are in armor and they
have reverse thrusters that have prevent
any damage to the surface they land on
or it's like Tony Stark crashing through
his house because yeah his suit is heavy
enough and absorbs the impact of that
shock or it's a super human who would
absorb the shock but just imagine if
they're landing in cracks or forms a
crater that shock is also going into
their body I think that's a sufficient
answer well done charlie
you're held at bay number two Yussef
wants to know how did they rebuild the
Bifrost after the bridge broke back in
Thor 1 ah this is a very good question
ok and we've been noticing this in our
recent infinity sorry watch so yeah just
catch people up in Avengers Thor got to
earth thanks to like dark energy that he
mentions from the all fathers Thor and
Loki return to Asgard to get the movie
with the power of the tesseract space
stone that allows teleportation but yeah
in Thor the dark world the bridge is
just repaired and if it's not explained
in the movie but it is explained in the
MCU prelude comic for Thor the dark
world to the comics
yeah the comics is just like it's right
away they return to Asgard and then
immediately third Heimdall use the
tesseract to quote let the fires of
Bifrost burn once more the space stone
to fix it stutter on Bifrost though they
do in the readers head yeah drives the
Bifrost of the bye-bye-bye what was that
guy maximum head or some [ __ ]
mmm maximum head you know what I'm
talking about no no no or what the Freak
was his name is a cool head zone or cool
man hey max max headroom he was just
like Mack it like this like weird like
glitchy eighties face
I'm significantly older than you are you
are right this is a real thing I just
it's outside of my reference space oh
yeah I'm sorry I should be essay in view
but I don't I'm not smart enough to
guess and you the true yes and is for
you to be honest
why did you date her right after me
that'll be the final episode of big
question x tweak really i think this is
a good question the reason it keeps
coming up is the rules of the Bifrost
have been like interpreted super
liberally by Marvel films ever since
like Heimdall does a voice command to
Bifrost hold back to earth and infinity
war he's just like he's got a remote
Bifrost power but he's got like one of
them cuz it's like a prayer store and
breaker has a Bifrost power which is
insane it's already super powerful
here's just a good rule of thumb for
anyone watching these movies Marvel did
not hold itself to its own rules and
really care about things like the
Bifrost the cinematic universe I would
say until around Winter Soldier like
lots of stuff in phase 1 and really the
first couple movies of phase 2 is just
ignored by the later films so we'd love
to like talk about the interconnectivity
and plans from the very beginning but
really they didn't really start thinking
like how this is all gonna be paying off
until the Russos took over around Winter
Soldier and then right around then was
age of Ultron - that's when Phi he's
like oh let's start figuring out where
the Xfinity stones are gonna be in here
and how long yeah and they changed it
all in retrospect in order for that to
work yeah it does make sense though you
know leading up to the Avengers where
they were like we might not get sequels
of any of these movies that's right they
just plan on
we don't know if this is gonna be a
success so we'll just kind of like go
for broke here and then we'll figure it
out later
like gotta bleep it another final
episode of alright this one's from disco
I was Nick wants to know in lost Oh a
lost question man we used to watch lost
so much I was our first like nerd outro
yeah that was like what how we got
started doing this stuff we would have a
little lost watch parties and everyone
had to be silent we had rules you
weren't allowed to speculate shut up
shut up I don't wish you weren't allowed
to react shut up because that might
spoil the end of the episode shut up we
lost all of our friends doing this well
and also to be clear if we watched it
your house and you had those rules
they're not not all of us fools but okay
in lost when they put the numbers in to
reset the clock do you remember is off
the top of your head for a high 4 8 15
23 32 40 30 I think it's 15 16 23 42 oh
there might be 16 and then yeah maybe
all right nerds I've lost all
credibility to answer this why does it
always go back to 108 minutes even if
they put in the code those numbers when
there's three minutes left on the clock
or one second left on the clock why does
it always go back to 108 well all right
well let's let's back up and just
quickly explain why they need to put in
these numbers so yes as we all know from
watching lost the island sits atop a
pocket of electromagnetic energy it was
absurd in the past by the Dharma
Initiative that was the incident and
ever since people in the Swan Lab have
had to in put these numbers in a
computer every 108 minutes and they have
to wait till like a four minute the four
minutes left on the clock and they have
to do that in order to prevent the
electromagnetism in that pocket from
accumulating to a disastrous level
building up if you let it expire as we
saw Desmond he did at the end of season
two in that flashback the
electromagnetism bursts out surges out
and causes disasters to happen and
that's what caused OC and at 8:15
crash on the island so if you are still
with me even though I mispronounced
electromagnetism symbiotes I think
whenever they put in those numbers what
it does is it safely Vince whatever
electric magnetism is in there so it
resets the levels back to zero so over
those 108 minutes it gradually builds
back up to a boiling point and when you
put in the numbers it doesn't like shift
the clock by 108 minutes back
it just goes imagine 108 minutes equals
zero on that energy buildup so it's like
emptying the garbage you don't you don't
empty your garbage by a certain
increment of garbage you just like empty
all of it whenever it builds up to it we
would you don't choose how much to flush
unless you got those two buttons yeah so
I think you're thinking of like oh
because the numbers themselves add up to
108 minutes that's how much it like
depletes it back by no that's just like
point zero that it ticks back down it
doesn't matter whether you're at like
three and a half minutes left on the
clock or one second on the clock it
always goes back to 108 you might be
thinking of edging I don't know what
that is
I'm thinking about it so but why just to
be clear why 108 the numbers themselves
add up to 108 and really like the
numbers I think we find out later
seasons each one represents a coordinate
for one of Jacob's chosen and then also
the numbers are like a quotient of an
algorithm that predicts mankind's
extinction there really it's like in the
lost universe the numbers are like the
show's version of the golden ratio it's
like a mathematically reoccurring
constant like PI or something it's you
know 108 minutes is just so happens to
be the natural period of that energy
buildup that has to get reset yeah it
makes me think of that secret Easter Egg
that we've been sneaking into all the
big question episodes oh no even if they
get something amazing if they find it
anyway so that's it that's that's those
questions oh but that means that it's
time for question box I'm remembering to
call it that this week the bag of mails
that's what you want yeah put them in a
bag you go I'll take one bag of mails
please rats a you feed to your snake
Clank Clank there's a lot of complaints
things you've gotten wrong in videos we
do read by the way all of the letter to
each other as we go to sleep at night so
we do appreciate when there when the
full-blown letters but you guys get in
the show just the question here and it
is from Mikey Moby what is the strangest
roadtrip experience you've ever had you
used to go on a lot of road trips in
college yeah we did and you know what
Phillip and I have had some really
really fun amazing road trips like I've
been blessed to have like pretty much
all great road trips in my life like
lots a good story but one of them was
awkward and awful so in college I my
junior year a couple of our friends were
able to go to the SEC championship game
we went to the University of Florida
Florida one that year they beat Alabama
in 2008 for the SEC championship game
and like five of our friends went and
had an amazing roadtrip experience they
took all these pictures it was a great
weekend they had a great time but like
you have to sign up for like a lottery
to get tickets for it they just don't
give you tickets if you're student you
have to like be lucky and get get it so
the next year was like we're all gonna
do it and I got you I got a bunch of our
other friends to like try to do it and
it was just me and this other girl who
got it and I was friends with her we all
were all part of the same improv cult
and the weekend before this SCC trip
we're gonna do a road trip together and
maybe a third person was gonna go with
us that person bailed well there was a
party as my roommates birthday party and
and we all got a little drunk in me and
this girl made out the the road trip
girl the road trip girl I assumed she
was single but know this story yeah I
picked her up at her apartment so we
could head up to Atlanta and helping her
put her backpack in the car was this
other dude that we knew and I knew like
a year prior that I won't when he had a
crush on her but I didn't I didn't think
anything had happened from it I was like
why is so-and-so helping you as we were
driving off and she goes oh he's been
he's been living with me I'm like wait
what and she's like yeah we're in a
relationship and I was like hold on then
why did we make out and she's like well
we're in an open relationship why did we
go all the way with a French kiss and
she said they were an open relationship
in college yeah okay nothing against
were open relationships actually as an
adult in college if you're in an open
relationship you're just cheating
because you don't understand the nuances
of open relationships yet you're just
not committed and this poor guy super
nice guy I thought I was on like great
terms with him he was super pissed at me
obviously I was like wait he was mad at
me did you tell him it she's like yeah
we don't have any secrets I was like but
you we just we've secrets from you right
and and we ran our end of the road trip
at this point and it's a six-hour drive
to Atlanta so the whole time we're
arguing about this and I'm like this guy
hates me now I had no ill-will towards
this guy I don't think any ill-will
towards me and she's like oh I thought
you hated him I thought you guys were
fighting that's like wait what no and
she's like will he talk [ __ ] to him that
one time like when did this happen
and she's like after that show what did
you you made fun of him after a show
that he did well no one did it I would
never make fun of them to his face we
made fun of each other constantly we
were [ __ ] in college we were super
judgy and mean but like I would never go
up to someone after show and talk [ __ ]
to him but apparently he misconstrued
something so this huge confusion he was
now he was like an open war with me so
the whole way we were just like not
happy with each other we get to the game
Florida gets destroyed in this game this
is a 2009 SEC championship game this is
a game where Tebow cries when bears say
that were decked out in Florida gear as
we're walking out all the Alabama fans
are making fun of us talking [ __ ] it was
it was heartbreaking and then we ended
up staying the night nothing else
happened because like I was mad and if
we drove back the entire way to
Gainesville in silence all right you
know what's so funny is that people are
like wow boss what a dog and then I want
you to realize that this is very similar
to the time that you dated my girlfriend
right after
I had just dated her it was right after
it was all so I'm gonna remind you of
the girl that was in your closet when
another girl came into your room that
was the same story but it's not on a
game with the story so I removed this
all other girl in that story Eric that
will be a future episode and I'll tell
the story from her point of view so
we'll be kind of like a you know sliding
doors yeah or just submitted out of
literati qey if you haven't already I
okay I also have a College Road Trip
story that you weren't on this is
actually right before you got to us you
were out there somewhere and you weren't
looking for me I and I had a different
friend named Eric Idle generally Eric s
he and I were really tight and we would
kept trying to make it into the
newspaper into the alligator like
everything we'd to be out in the
alligator and we kept being successful
and one of the things that we did was we
submitted and we got picked by Chevy to
be our representatives for our school
and a nationwide contest to win a car
and you had to do that thing we have to
keep your hand on the car for as long as
possible
and you can't lift your hand up and very
long story short we lost that thing but
which by the way like we lost them like
the first hour because I talk with my
hands anyway oh my the Chevy
representative was like your hand and
she like looked around like nobody had
know we hadn't even launched the event
so but whatever so we had been like
getting to know the other schools via
like really shitty webcam because
remember this is the 70s and so we were
talking to these two girls who are at
this other school and they are also
losing so we're like making fun of the
team that's winning at USC and these
girls Carey and Aria actual Aria they
there's just this like rapport and like
we both know what we're going through
and so it starts to become like this
like double date session that we keep
doing and the the whole event ends but
and we don't win but Chevy hits us up
later and they're like hey you guys had
the most entertaining of the feeds we
think you guys are just so hilarious
then they knew we did comedy and they're
like we want
we have a surprise for you and they
surprised us with we want you to do a
cross-country road trip performing
stand-up comedy we had only done improv
and sketch comedy to the point no
stand-up comedy at all but they're like
performing stand-up comedy your
wheelhouse all across the country on
this road trip we want you to meet those
girls that you that you guys like we're
flirting with the whole time and then he
was the Big Finish you're going to get
to this is tells you the time period
you're gonna get to perform on The
Tonight Show with Jay Leno and you're
gonna be you know you're gonna be the
comedy slot at the end of the show and
we were like let's think about it but we
do it and so it's like Thanksgiving
instead of doing Thanksgiving we do this
so we drive I don't know how to drive
stick and they give us the shittiest car
that his only stick so I learned how to
drive stick in the parking lot I just
like really ruining the stupid little of
a oh that cost like $88 they Jam like a
secret cameraman in the backseat in this
tiny car and he's like six three and he
stinks and and we start driving in it's
like so hot because it's in this it's
the most of the trip is just through the
south so we're driving from Jacksonville
all the way here to LA we're going and
we stopped and the first time we stopped
to perform and and there remember
Chevy's recording everything we perform
our stupid stand-up style it's like like
sketch stand-ups that we came up with
and the guy goes around to get audience
reactions the girls say well there's are
like like they just got some girls and
they're like oh yeah very cute and the
guy was like yeah but are they gonna
make it in LA and they were like oh
they're trying to like make it in LA
like yeah they're like comedians she's
like oh no it's like like and then and
then she was like but the dark-haired
one's cute and I was like oh sweet and
then she totally meant just the other
Eric who also has both of you have dark
exactly so I had nothing going for me at
this time and we still were like just
really trying to rewrite this thing so
then Chevy gets nervous and they're like
hey your comedy set isn't really giving
us the footage that we were hoping for
so instead and these are early days of
YouTube they're like we need you to
start going viral as much as you can
just do things that will go viral so
they have a stop in in Louisiana and
they're like just go like rile up some
people but try to like make something
happen
so there's just this old coot just of
course because it's Baton Rouge and his
name is Seamus and he has no teeth and
we're like we want to do something crazy
in Baton Rouge and he's like well you
can try to drink this hot sauce that we
have here but you know nobody can
normally take it it's too intense and
we're like alright and he's like alright
hey they're gonna drink it or whatever
so both Eric and I each get a bottle we
open it and we chug the entire bottle
and it is insanely painful it is so bad
and then like we start we need to like
water and like we're eventually coming
down and they're like great this is so
viral and then Seamus says like yeah I
can't believe you two done did that and
we're like yeah well you know we were
crazy or whatever he's like last guy
that did it died oh no he told us that
after we had chugged it and so then they
loved the shameless content so they're
like you got to do more with this
toothless guy so we take him with us for
a little while and we go to this like
for people at this car now me and Eric
in the front seat me barely been able to
drive stick giant cameraman and Seamus a
toothless redneck and we go and we find
a mountain range to climb because
climbing mountains would go viral for
some reason I think they realized that
we clearly didn't know anything about
climbing so they were hoping one of us
would fall which I kept screaming I'm
like the only way this is gonna go viral
is if we fall
and so we climb it and we get down like
Sheamus had like led us to this place
and we just we do nothing we climb it
and then and then we come back down and
he's like y'all okay and like yeah it
was just a stupid climb and he's like
well that's all rattlesnake nest you got
there this famous guys trying to kill
you exactly and he points out all the
different places we've been putting our
hands that were just Rauh snake nest so
we come back down we tell chevy no more
viral moments we're more famous and
they're like yeah this is now our CEO
exactly yeah
Sheamus is short for Chevy myths so we
we leave him just in a ditch or
something and then we keep going to LA
to do our big comedy show and perform
for Jay Leno and we we get all the way
there and I guess like you know
he'd been sent our stuff on the way
there and we go and we meet Jay Leno
backstage of the Tonight Show and he
talks to us and he just makes fun of us
viciously the whole time there and then
he makes fun of the Chevy car because
he's like really car obsessed he's like
what do you speak Korean because if you
don't you can't drive that car which is
just like kind of racist I guess and
then we get to go sit in the audience
and we're like this is weird shouldn't
we be in a green room and then they just
didn't have a comedy guest at that time
he had blocked it he said no those guys
aren't performing comedy on The Tonight
Show so all we got to do is we got to go
see Taylor Hicks
okay supplies and we like Taylor Hicks
makes it all worth it and we got yelled
at for not liking Taylor Hicks enough to
be featured on camera okay so yeah the
audience people they wanted to be over
enthusiam exactly and so that's when we
gave up on our Hollywood dreams and I
never moved to LA I stayed with Seamus
and we we have a lot of kids today
Blaine rattlesnakes would it be fun if
Seamus did get on The Tonight Show he
ends up doing a carpool karaoke Seamus
is now Conan's boss man that guy's doing
great he probably dead now but still
great job hey guys
bye hand sanitizer hey yeah you know
help us out that is our show a reminder
that you can join our official discord
by becoming a patron at patreon.com
slash new rockstars and didn't get an
audio version of the show by subscribing
to a new rockstars big question wherever
you get your podcasts hey thanks to
everyone who submitted questions this
week some really really fun questions
you can send us your big questions on
twitter using the hashtag big question
or you can mail us at our p o-- box
follow me Eddie a boss follow Phillip at
Phillip Malina and followed new rock
stars on social media subscribe here on
YouTube to get too much information all
with stuff you care about see you next
week Philip bye see ya
[Music]